welcome back we've got Andrew rolds and
Josh Gad with us give it up
everybody so our new Broadway show is
called Gutenberg the musical and since
we are all obsessed with Broadway now
would be a nice time to talk about some
of our other favorites in life this is
called
obsessions
obsessions Andrew did it with you that's
right it is time to own up to our
obsessions weird or not for the first
time in our New York City Studio I love
being here I'm going to hit this button
and a topic will be selected by our
super random super computer which
apparently followed us from La um then
the person obsessed with the topic will
own up and sell us on their Obsession I
will get us started here we go
okay
oh I I share this Obsession you are we
going to do it next season you want to
do will happily be in your fantasy oh my
God oh my gosh we should do it I'm I
it's my first season I'm obsessed Lester
happened to kick my behind this last
weekend but I didn't really know the
players as well and now I'm obsessed now
I'm like watching games that were on
weeks ago just to study up yeah wow
you're really you're going I'm really
into it because I like a game you see
Andrew yeah and fantasy football is fun
he keeps trying to get me to watch the
sportsall I will literally I'll I'll be
I'll be on Sundays with our show starts
at 3: I'll be backstage watching on my
iPad football games absolutely and
Andrew will walk by and go you watching
sportsball again exactly I couldn't do
it this year because I'm so committed to
work yeah you're very and so I have't
you're I am not committed to work and I
was like I'm doing it I'll I'll play
your yes it's so fun if you like a game
anyway okay it's next oh gosh oh God I
oh I'm getting it cuz I'm trolling okay
perfect being brushed I'm going to I'm
going to admit this my my girls this is
very specific my girls got my girls got
obsessed with videos of animals being
brushed and I was like this is the
weirdest Obsession and then I got sucked
into it so we now
well I thank you oh that's all it takes
it's an obsession now so my wife and my
girls and I every day we send each other
videos of
animals there's like a little bit of
like a transference like an ASMR
situation calms you down I I this is my
way of telling you I wish you would
brush me
occasionally josy I'll brush you yeah
just a little conb yeah you brush your
hair Andrew you oh I get to do what's
Happ I touched it oh m is yeah okay oh
oh all right I can get behind that this
is recent for pot do you like a one pot
this recent for me I'm obsessed okay
yeah yeah well you just throw it all in
you put it in there even if you don't
have a crock poot kids you use um you
can use like a you know a dutch oven or
you know no not a microwave now what's a
dutch oven T dut like one of those like
lack
cruset this is taking a it's like a cast
iron
pot that you can put everything in okay
yes but a crock poot I'm from Nebraska
we like a Crockpot yeah and a dutch oven
apparently KY Clark it's very different
I love that you needed to qualify it
with a quality crock poot like as if as
if there was confusion that you wanted
garbage crockpot it's hard to do a
garbage crock that's the thing about
crock poot see I don't like cooking but
you throw it all in spices it's pretty
good and then walk out I'll give you
some recipes yeah I'm a lazy cook This
Is My Vibe yeah this is perfect all
right I'll I'll send you some all right
recipes don't lie send it to me I'll it
okay okay here we go okay I'm hitting it
I'm hit it what do you got what do you
got
oh do you Do You Love it do you love it
do you love it yeah obsessed yes OB I
mean it's the greatest show on TV right
can I admit something to you yes I went
to the white room last week on stage
well I went to I went did you did you
reenact Steve Martin in the thing well
no I what happened was I I I so in only
murders in the building Steve Martin
goes to the white room where you blank
when you're in performance and you are
suddenly out of your body and I grab the
wrong hat there's like one hat that I'm
not supposed to touch in the entire show
and I found that I was holding it but I
never remembered picking it up I totally
went to the white room like at times in
the Book of Mormon we were like six
eight months in and you'd forget
something that you did times a week and
you were like how am I forgetting this
now for the first time I imagine you
know why you were thinking about quality
Crock-Pot
wrest I was thinking about that and he
was playing fantasy football he was
probably playing sports sportsall okay
think about his teams do I get to this
this time just the one
time what are we got why does it even
light up for me no we it's a rough
budget it's a rough budget oh sure sure
sure internet rabbit holes after
watching the crown I hear I hear you on
this one I watch the crown never I I
literally so great forget it I go down a
rabbit hole of researching the events of
the crown that I just watched what's
true what's not true so the the the
Romanov everything I knew about the
romanovs was from Fox's animated an oh
my gosh it's so great knew nothing else
so I watch this I watch I watch an
episode of the crown it's very different
than the animated Anastasia movie yeah
yeah yeah um spoiler alert she didn't
survive she's dead so I learned this
from the CR she's she doesn't sing
Journey To The Past no she doesn't S she
doesn't sing much but that's I hear you
I do the same any sort of historical
yeah you're like is that true I must
know if they're lying to me you it makes
me realize how much I was not paying
attention in high school that I know
nothing about isn't that weird that
later in life you really enjoy history
but like when you're supposed to be
learning it you're like this is boring
if it was on a TV show I would have been
hooked exactly now they're doing both
that was a great soundtrack by the way
Anastasia oh great sound oh so good okay
and those were our
Obsession the duet the duet that Jesse
and Andrew are having is is nice okay
Josh and Andrew's new Broadway show is
called Gutenberg the musical go see it
playing now until January
[Music]
[Applause]
28th thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home